is scott disick moving on from kourtney
kardashian at the end of the day i mean
you just want to be happy you want to be
content e.t is hearing although he's a
tad jealous of court and travis barker's
relationship he's being respectful of
the husband and wife to be well yeah a
source tells e.t that scott will always
love courtney and probably never
completely move on but he's being chill
and mature about his ex's engagement
we've been through so much in so many
things what's most important to scott is
that travis is good to their kids and
treats her well i mean i think you just
gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day so back to
scott moving on from court et's learned
the 38 year old reality star has a new
woman in his life 23 year old model
holly scarfoan who appeared on season 3
of too hot to handle dating speculation
between the pair sparked earlier this
week when holly shared this lingerie
shot on instagram and tagged scott with
photo credit according to et source the
two have been hooking up and things
between them are casual right now so
while scott's keeping things casual
courtney's full steam ahead on wedding
planning our source tells us the two
want to get married soon and are looking
into dates now i love it she's so into
it and in love travis is letting
courtney plan everything but he has
input and great ideas so it's mutual
planning i really learned how
to
keep it all together like it's actually
kind of annoying how much of a
perfectionist i am now and i think she
is it is annoying we all are it's like
just something mental like i'm like ah
like little things that like i'm
constantly writing things down in my
phone lists or this or that but it's
like
it also it keeps it all together going
it keeps it all together fans will
possibly get tons of wedding planning
footage in the family's new hulu series
the kardashians over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
this is day one we already got a small
glimpse of the pair's engagement in the
trailer i love us
this makes me so happy
she's never had a reaction like that for
me and it's happened like a few times we
love to see it and that's not the first
time sister kim has shown support for
courtney's happily ever after i love
their relationship she stopped by the
ellen degeneres show last year and had
nothing but sweet things to say about
courtney and travis's strong
relationship they've
grown so much together and have really
like made some amazing um
just i mean to think that they've been
neighbors and friends for almost 15
years neighbors for like a decade and
then all of a sudden yeah they cannot
keep their hands off of each other i
mean like
like they it's amazing crazy what is
wrong with them it's so cute and i love
love so i love them
[Music]